oh my gosh
okay I've had a rheumatoid arthritis
since 30 age of 32 so I know what it's
like to have bad knees but but
you know it's a martial arts got to put
up with it haven't I
said no no easy method
Osa they grab your hands
what we've been doing all day
keep in that Central spot if you go
like that that's all right if you're big
and strong about if he's holding me
firmly there I can't there is a way you
go back here leaving your hands there
but you know what I'm doing now
anybody
no I'm gonna do morotie Dory
watch where my shoulder goes
so I'm going away from him but I can't
take the center
but I can soften that over there so
there is a technique like this
so there's lots of variations
oh that's lovely bit of music
but if I go here
I mustn't go in I mustn't go out I must
just turn them over
I'm now from my Center going to choose a
hand and I'm going to imagine there's a
rod from my Center to my hand to push my
hand
so that will give me the stimulus of
connection and that'll give me the
stimulus of
thinking that thinking or imagining
something that's attached
it's all this waving about you know you
can't do it when I somebody like me
you know he can feel it already you know
my power my Mass
is not going anywhere
you know
so you've got to think that everybody
again this judge judgment not to
you've got to think that everybody's
going to be stronger than you if you
work on that assumption you do the least
amount
to get the maximum amount
one
two one two not one two
two
this spinning
gives you power
spinning gives you power because I'm
connected my Center
and that gives me power all right so you
don't have to move a lot on your knees
if you've got bad knees
ah
you know if you want to add a scream a
shout to it some coke here
but what I mustn't do for you seniors
it's more important for you seniors what
I mustn't do is when I key I have some
want behind it take that because as soon
as I do that I've just destroyed the
whole purpose
ah
okay okay do your best this is left of
my